last time on davinci resolve editing we
went through all the basic setup how to
do some standard effects and kind of get
used to the interface
and then how to deliver your product
and render it out
and this time we're going to talk about
another pretty important feature of
resolve and that's just about overlaying
your voice audio
there's a couple different ways to do
this
some of the most obvious ways might be
to record with other software and then
bring the audio in but you don't really
need to do that with resolve as i will
show you
how to do voice overlays and davinci
resolve so open it up like normal we're
gonna do an untitled project it's
opening in my other window for some
reason so bring it over
but what we're going to do is uh bring
in a clip to work with first of all so
we're going to go back you know go to
wherever you store your videos of course
bring in whatever you want
kind of covered this last time i'm just
going to grab something sort of small
looking like this i don't know what this
is
i'll change it
looks like it's a mtg game say i'm just
wanting to comment over this game one of
the things you can do is pull up
something like audacity
uh this here and you can always record
here make sure you got your microphone
set
go hello test test
right you got some audio and you can
export it and then you could bring it in
here and do that manually but we can
skip this whole audacity phase and i'll
show you how to do that
so what you do
is down at the bottom here
go to the audio
fairlight is what it's called
and you want to add a new track
specifically for your recordings so down
here you just right click
go to add tracks and you can do mono or
stereo depending on what your mic is i'm
going to do mono because i'm pretty sure
my mic is mono anyway
and then there's a couple things that
happen here so you get your audio
there's an arm for record now this is
important
but also you'll notice that once you
click this
if it even lets you well it's not
letting me right now and that's because
there's no input so to arm it for
recording an input
and you can do that over here in the
mixer where you'll see audio 2
and there's no input listed so you can
click this
and click input
and it brings up this whole panel
and you should see the microphone you
want somewhere i have mine over here the
c media usb device that's uh that's my
main
device so i'm going to click that and
patch and now that's going to patch it
in
as the main input audio
so you'll have more stuff here if you
have more
inputs and mics and stuff
but
if you have a pretty standard setup you
should just see your mic and be able to
patch it in and then once you patch it
in you can close this and now you'll
notice that this will allow you to arm
for record
and it also echoes back and
it's kind of confusing so you can
mute the track and that way it won't
echo back in your ears all the time
while you're talking over
of course you want to unmute it before
you actually release this but
what's going to happen now is if you hit
record here
you'll see what you're what's going on
in your video
and you'll be able to just start talking
over it so i'm going to mute
this audio one that's actually coming
from the video two
for now just so it doesn't mess with me
but do as you want so you get it to
where you want in the video right
and you can start commenting i'll do a
little example
so once i click record here i'm going to
start talking and i'm just going to kind
of say random stuff so
uh just as the example
maybe here five seconds
i wanted to show you guys this epic mtg
arena play now check out this
uh
superhuman deck where i am swinging with
a full party of rogues wizards warriors
and this was a pretty interesting game
and now i'm just doing a voice overlay
and davinci resolve yeah that's right
this guy's swinging with three three no
blocks here we're coming back strong
so there you go now hit stop but you see
i've got this whole clip here
and
now if we go back to our edit area
we'll see that this stuff is of course
still here and we got some mutes so if
we unmute it
we can listen back we can go over here
and say see how it sounds i wanted to
show you guys this epic mtg arena play
now
as you can see it sounds pretty clear
now this is all going to vary with your
mic and your setup of course
of how clear it sounds but generally
this does a pretty good job of that and
you can get that in your mix with a nice
little overlay check out this
uh
superhuman so if you've got videos that
need a voiceover this is a quick way to
do it so just drop it right in the
resolve
go over here okay now it's that going
back go over here and and do that whole
setup the arm for record or what this
selector input the arm for record and
then uh mute is needed hit record here
and it's gonna record on that armed
track
uh just to mention it there are other
ways
to do this whole microphone setup too i
think that i forget where it's at but
there's somewhere up here
it's probably under fair light like bus
a sign or something i don't know one of
these there's other ways to get to this
microphone input setup i always just use
this button
all right well that's basically it
for how to do that you can just patch
those in as needed all over your video
as you're editing you might come up with
something where you're like oh i want to
make an editor comment here or there
this is a perfect way to do it it's just
patching this audio
and just uh just talk real quick that
way you don't have to open up another
program export import do all that and
just pop over to fairlight another great
feature of resolve i hope you guys have
enjoyed episode two i just want to keep
this short and sweet and concise on this
one in case anyone needs to find this
exact thing
so if you look up other tutorials you
might see people uh saying go somewhere
else but uh yeah there you go
see you guys next time matt go technical
tutorials
foreign